[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUKMAN RAMSEY:
Thanks for coming.
This is MLAI223--
Customer Stories--
Transforming Businesses
with Cloud AI Solutions.
So today we're going
to hear from several--
three, as a matter of fact--
Google Cloud customers about
their own stories transforming
their businesses using AI and
ML technologies on Google Cloud.
So the speakers today
are going to come
from three different customers.
We're going to start
with hearing from Minori
Matsuda from Nissen.
Then we're going to hear
from Laura Bandura at Chevron
and finally, from Justin
Hopson from Hitachi Consulting.
And at the end of
the session, there
should hopefully be a
little bit of time for Q&A.
There is a Dory
for this session,
as there have been for many
of the other breakouts.
So if you go to
this link, you will
be able to ask questions to
the presenters that we will--
if we don't get to them
at the end of the session,
we will make sure to
answer them in the Dory
by the end of the conference.
So I'm going to spend just
a few minutes recapping
some of the things
that you heard
this morning at the keynote
from Rajen Sheth, the PM
for Cloud AI about
Cloud AI solutions.
We've announced several
new Cloud AI solutions
here at Next.
The idea behind
these solutions is
to combine the Google AI
expertise and the products
that you're already familiar
with with an ecosystem,
a partner services and
partner technology services,
to enable the deployment of
end to end AI solutions that
utilize your data, but that
you can plug into your existing
technology and workflows
to solve an end
to end business problem.
So let's dig in a little deeper.
Again, these
solutions are targeted
towards all of the
verticals that you see here,
including retail and
manufacturing, health care,
media and entertainment,
and so on.
And the focus is on not just
building a machine learning
model to do predictions
for a particular use case,
but rather, building an
end to end solution that
takes the data in,
pre-processes the data,
runs it through a model, and
then serves those results out
to an end application that your
team may integrate with to,
again, solve a real
business problem.
So one of the key
new announcements
we've made here next
for a Cloud AI solution
is the new document
understanding AI.
Again, a comprehensive
solution targeted on document
and understanding many
different kinds of documents.
It'll allow you to extract
insights from these documents,
and it's basically a
core building block
for what could be an
end to end solution
for document management,
document control,
and so on in your business.
We also announced here at
Next, Recommendations AI,
which is a state of
the art AI service
that allows retail customers
to power recommendations.
It's a fully managed service.
It's very easy to upload
your data to this service
to do the integration.
And then you can deliver
those recommendations
to any endpoint.
So you can integrate them
with your existing website,
for example.
And we've seen dramatic results
from our initial deployments
over the past year
or year and a half
with several customers
in the retail space,
including eye dropping
numbers like 90% lift in click
through rates, and 40%
lift in conversions,
and in some cases, big
lifts in revenue as well.
And then finally, I want to
mention the Contact Center AI.
This was actually
announced at the last Next,
but we've continued to expand
and build on this solution.
And it's a great example, again,
of a suite of technologies
that's all oriented towards
solving a particular business
problem, namely enabling an
AI powered contact center
or taking your
existing contact center
and injecting it
with AI capabilities.
So again, this is all part
of a very comprehensive set
of tools and building
blocks that we have in now
in Cloud AI, including many of
the other announcements we made
at here at Next, including
things like AutoML tables,
something that I'm
extremely excited about.
And actually, this
is AI Platform now.
I think the name was changed
just before the conference.
As well as all of the hardware
acceleration and the frameworks
that we support.
TensorFlow obviously, but
other common frameworks
for Machine Learning,
including scikit-learn, Spark,
and PyTorch.
As well as a growing ecosystem
of Machine Learning partners
that can help you
build your solution.
You can work with Google
to deploy the solution
or in many cases, Google
plus a partner and yourselves
will build a solution together.
And again, we have a very
large and growing set
of solution partners to
help you on this journey.
All right.
With that, I'm going to
introduce our first customer
speaker.
This is Minori Matsuda,
data scientist at Nissen.
Minori, welcome to the stage.
MINORI MATSUDA:
Thank you very much.
And today, I talk about
the recommendation system
built on GCP.
First of all, I'm Minori and a
data scientist at 7&i Holdings.
And mainly, I'm doing
the Machine Learning.
And let me introduce my
company and our group.
Our group is one of the
biggest retail in Japan,
and it's based on mail
marketing originally
and we are covering most of
the household data in Japan
at over 30 median
household data in Japan.
And we are mainly retailing
the fashionable items.
This is our company.
And in total, our
data, we are processing
the natural language
and the product images
and the customer attribution
data and the customer behavior
log, such as the
product description
and the customer label, the
natural language processing,
these are mainly Japanese.
In the 1 million plus images and
the over 30 million households,
as I said.
And of course we are
literally on the website,
so we have a website catalog
to find many transaction data.
OK.
And now we have a
three challenges
that we had before we
use the Google Cloud.
One is the need to create
the model from scratch.
So we have many data, so
label unique product features
from the database.
And second is agile
and modeling speed.
And we issued five times
per year the paper catalog.
So we do in the modeling to over
200 various and making a model.
But it's really slow to adapt
to the website business speed.
And the number three, the
interoperability of the model.
And most of algorithms and
most of the software package
is the black box inside.
So I cannot feedback to the
business side to explain about
model.
And the surveys needed to
launch within a few months.
That overview.
This is one of the examples
of the image similarity based
item recommendation.
So, technically, a
feature extracted
by convolutional neural
network and doing
the unsupervised
learning by TensorFlow.
The most thing we'll
find the left side
that dress and the right side
dress is a similar product.
The machine can recognize it.
And I will show a little bit
interesting video about this.
How am I seeing
recognizable images?
I brought the 10,000 product
images on this, the TensorBot.
TensorBot is a visualization
tool for TensorFlow.
And as you can see, there
are many, many products.
And I give the task to
the machine to clustering.
Clustering.
This is the
unsupervised learning.
And I don't tell the machine
that these lines are bad
and that these lines I chose.
I do not tell to the
machine, but the machine
can automatically
classify like this.
This is called the
dimension reduction.
Originally, each point has
the 300 dimensional vectors,
but after that, the machine can
recognize that classification.
This is the bed,
that is the bed.
Yeah.
Like this.
And also, the machine can
understand, as you may know,
the language, natural language
such as word and the document.
And same as before,
giving a task
for unsupervised learning
of their natural language,
the machine will tell that
the lumbago and the posture
is similar languages.
And it's corrupting.
OK.
By assembling in the
data, assembling in data--
this might be hard
to see, but we
are assembling
the two algorithms
such as the structured data
and structured data such as DNN
and the CNN.
And what do we get from deep
learning is the machine finds
product affinity by itself, and
the machine can predict before
selling and overcome the
cold-start program such
as the customer has no data,
we cannot recommend anything
but that we overcome
the cold-start problem.
And then, finally, this is
beyond human understanding.
If we teach to the machine that
this is the cute-- "kawaii"
is cute in Japanese,
the kawaii--
we tell it, what
is the kawaii, what
is the cuteness to the
machine, the machine
will understand this.
The machine will capture
what is the cute,
the feature of the cuteness.
And after the machine learned
the cuteness, as you can see,
the machine generates the
cute human woman underwear.
And then, these products
do not exist in real.
And they must be
generated, and we
are going to sell it in
real in a competition
against a human product manager.
OK then, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
LUKMAN RAMSEY:
Thank you, Minori.
All right.
Next, we have, from
Chevron, Laura Bandura.
LAURA BANDURA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Laura Bandura, and
I'm a research geophysicist
at Chevron.
In the oil and gas industry
we have so much data, legacy
and modern data.
It's sequestered
across clouds, tapes,
and multiple internal file
systems, and in some cases even
on paper.
If we cannot rapidly
unearth this information,
then the value of this
information is reduced
significantly.
The large projects
that we work on
tend to be very large and
very cross-functional.
They're very global and they
require a large diversity
of people with different
technical expertise
on different languages.
And we all work
together to attempt
to bring value with all
of this diversity in mind.
And this helps us, ultimately,
to make better decisions.
So just as one would use Google
Earth to explore the subsurface
and to organize information
on the surface of the Earth,
we really want to expand this
into an additional dimension
in time and in depth.
And this is where we
utilize our information.
And we often work at
multiple timescales
where we have the age of the
rocks, which is the largest
timescale that we work at.
And even at a much
smaller timescale
we have the asset
lifetime, which
can range from decades to
even a century in some cases.
At the smallest
scales, then we're
looking at our business
processes in real time
and monitoring business
operations around the world.
But most importantly, we
need to access information
related to all aspects
of our business,
both quickly and efficiently.
So now I'd like to
introduce you to Anne,
a petrophysicist in our San
Joaquin Valley business unit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It is home to some
of the largest oil
fields in the world.
For example, Midway
Sunset Oilfield
is the third largest
in the United States
and the largest in California.
It has about 35,000 wells.
Now, each one of those
wells has a paper
well file where critical
information about the well
is stored.
And those can range
from being fairly
small sized stacks of paper--
you can go through some
of these pretty quickly--
to just enormous monsters
full of analysis and data.
No.
I don't usually have to go
through the paper files anymore
because most of them
have been scanned.
So I go through
the PDFs by hand.
Most of the time, I know
data is already there,
I can go and find it.
And then, when I find something
really important, print it.
But I also stumble across
really interesting things.
This is a file which is a copy
of a record of all the rocks
that were drilled from
the well from 1911.
And this is a
really snarky letter
that somebody wrote about
their samples being mistreated.
Usually, when I find
something that I'm going
to actually need, I print it.
And this is a rail stack
that I'm working with.
And this is fine.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURA BANDURA: So
as Anne suggested,
we have an
opportunity to improve
on how we access legacy data
and documents to support
our decisions now.
So now let's take
a look at how we
have addressed this
challenge with tools on GCP.
In order to dig deeper into
the content of our documents,
we first need to break them
down into the parts that can
be analyzed in a custom way.
This requires each
document to be segmented
and then these segments are
classified into either text
tables or images.
And then we have to order them
in order to holistically put
them into context.
When a document is classified
as an image such as this one,
it's important to
extract the labels that
are within the image, as well
as the details within the image.
So in this case, we
have a geologic model.
For some applications,
it's important for us
to understand those pieces as
well as the whole image itself.
It's also important that
we capture that information
within tables and to
transform these tables which
in documents are in an
unstructured data format,
we want to put these into
a structured data format
so that they can be used
by our analysis tools
in a much more efficient way.
Our documents contain a
variety of image types
that are specific to the
geosciences, many of which
that you can see here.
These range from seismic
data to earth models,
to geologic maps, and much more.
Some of you may
remember from Next 18
that we used AutoML Vision
to classify these image.
With AutoML, it's
straightforward to customize
the classification scheme to
our Earth model content or Earth
science content.
We simply upload hundreds
of images that we have,
and then we upload
hundreds of images,
and then we label them with
some of the image labels
that you see here.
And then, within a
matter of minutes,
we can already have
an initial model
that can help us train our
model to classify everything
that we have on our system.
And then this can be
used to make that content
searchable further.
The AutoML interface
is very easy to use.
There are very
simple tools that are
shown to the user, such as
the AutoML-generated confusion
matrix right here.
This is a very
straightforward way
that and an expert
in the geosciences
can understand where maybe they
may need to add more training
examples to improve the model or
make other changes to increase
the accuracy.
In some cases,
maybe they just need
to train the model longer in
order to get a better result.
But these types of
outputs are very
easy for just normal subject
matter experts in subjects
other than machine learning.
So technical experts to use.
And that's what we find
very useful about AutoML.
So as you can see
from the diagram here,
AutoML is not all that
we needed in order
to make this work to make
everything searchable,
so I'm going to call up
Kenton Prindle to talk
about this in more detail.
And for the last
couple of years,
we've had a great
partnership with Google
and he has helped us implement
this within our company.
And take it away, Kenton.
KENTON PRINDLE:
Thank you, Laura.
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
So, yes.
As Laura mentioned, we've
been working together
for quite a while now
on how to characterize
these documents at a
meta level and then also
at the segment level.
So as you can see on
the left-hand side--
first, I mentioned
that, of course,
this was last year's
information that we basically
built with Chevron.
And essentially, we're moving
past that quite aggressively
now to supplement
segmentation, as she
mentioned before,
but also well logs,
LES files, and segue files.
And our focus here is
actually connect it altogether
for true analog search.
And so what we're
after is stuff that we
can get greater and
greater and deeper
insights into the
world's dataset,
not just data assets dataset.
So on the left-hand side, you'll
see that the ingestion process
is just simply just
triggered by emptying
your files into a
bucket, and the bucket
triggers a whole
series of events that
automatically process the data.
So it goes to GSC
storage, Pub/Sub
handles all these events,
and moves to Cloud Dataflow.
Dataflow is only tasked
with one purpose, which
is to break it into pages.
The pages then can be
paralyzed for processing
in the segmentation
space, right?
So we go into the page,
we segment the page
as a human readable flow, right?
So we keep all the text,
we keep all the images
in the right order.
So that it was as if a human
was reading the document.
Later in life, this would
become evident of why.
It takes a long time to
do this, but we want not
only the semantic expressions
of how the document information
flows, we want sentiment.
And sentiment is very,
very hard to achieve
without keeping the word flow
of the entire vector space
consistent.
So we're doing this
for some reason
later, which we'll talk about.
And then, of course, once
we get this information
on the second level,
we're actually passing it
through a whole series of APIs.
So these APIs are, of
course, AutoML Vision, NLP,
and Translation
amongst a few others.
And the whole
point here is we're
trying to figure out, with
every one of these holes,
whether they're an image, a
table, an equation, a drilling
diagram, a table,
whatever it is, text.
And so once we get
this, we actually
run that adaptively
through the algorithm
to figure out the information
we want off of it.
Once we do that, we actually
pass that into a Cloud Machine
Learning Engine called to
figure out a word to back,
an image to bacl
encoded dual model.
Right?
And so in this
case, we're trying
to figure out what the
type of the document is.
So we're not stopping it, just
getting the information out
for just general keyword search.
We're trying, then, to
go deeper and say, well,
this is a drilling report
or this is a composite log.
Whatever it is, we're
trying to make it easy
so you can do filter search
as well as just true vector
search.
From that point, Pub/Sub
delivers that back
to the GCS archive, and all
of the segments of interest
are saved there for display.
And then, of course,
we index those either
to Cloud Search
or Elasticsearch.
Cloud Search is our
preferred method
because we can scale much
more, but Elasticsearch
works perfect, as well.
And then, of course,
we've integrated
dialog flows that you can
talk to your interface.
But that's not a
big focus of this.
Ultimately, what we end
up with is the documents
on a map with the
ability to search images
or text, or images and text.
All right.
So why are we doing all this?
We're not just doing it
to pull up the images
and pull up this
information, we're
trying to integrate
all the data, right?
And so on the top
you'll see that we
have classic kind of digital
data that we experience a lot,
we see well logs and
seismic, Earth models.
These things are reasonably
well formatted and understood.
And then we're trying to
take the glue between those
and the interpretation
or the documents, right?
They are the true
interpretations
that we're actually getting
from these upper images.
So what we've done
recently with Chevron
is we've built a
knowledge graph that
can handle the entity
resolution and geolocate
based on that resolution.
So at this point, we've got LES
curves, we've got segue files,
we've got any kind of attribute
of any of those feature sets.
And we've got the documents
tied to those features
in a connected similarity in
that 3D space, such as this.
So you see here on the left, we
have this well log in seismic.
It's pretty obvious when you
do this as a geophysicist
that this well log belongs
to this piece of seismic.
That's the classic
kind of view of this.
But when you don't actually
have this stuff into a project,
it's actually quite
hard to understand
where the state is connected.
So on the right-hand tops,
you see the Knowledge Graph
representation of this.
And you'll see that we'd
have nice Knowledge Graph
nodes connecting who
is the operator, what
did this log and or
field from the document--
was it an oil producing field?
Was it the Scott field?
And the point here is, now, when
you search for these things,
you're getting back the analog
system, not just the data
that you're looking for.
We get all the
features that belong
to that particular
search term if you're
looking for a finite object.
But then if you look
for a general object,
like a porous sandstone of
north-west Shell Australia,
for example, you actually
might light up a world
map and say here all
the Triassic sounds
that actually have
relevant features that
are similar to this.
And that's kind of
our goal in the space.
Back to Laura.
LAURA BANDURA: All right.
So this is really just
the beginning for us.
We started from an Earth
science proof of concept
where we applied these
methods to exploration, asset
development, and
operations but now
we are really on a
journey to embracing
the opportunity for impacts
across our entire enterprise,
where we can move unto drilling
completions, facilities,
and health environment
and safety.
So we see so much hope
for this application
and we're looking
forward to expanding it.
Thank you.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Thank
you Laura and Kenton.
Our next and final speaker is
Justin Thompson from Hitachi.
Sorry.
Hopson.
JUSTIN HOPSON: Thanks, Lukman.
As it says here,
I'm Justin Hopson.
I'm a senior data scientist with
Hitachi's consulting division
with the professional
services arm.
And I want to talk to you
today about a customer story.
This is something that might
be relevant to some of you
in the room, for
others, you may not
be as familiar with
this background.
We're going to talk
about damage from
the recent electric utility
fires here in California.
There have been impacts here.
We've had human
fatalities, we've
had liability, litigation.
This is something very
important to our community.
And we saw this
as an opportunity
to get involved
and understand what
are the historical patterns
that have led to utility
caused fires.
In particular, we're going to
focus on the electrical grid
and what were the conditions
that exist prior to fire
ignition and see if we can model
where those conditions occur
again in the future.
So that'll be the first
part of this talk.
I want to go through some
of the data, the training
and the validation some of
the mapping and the output,
and then, more
importantly, can we
actually turn it into action?
It's great to have the
insight, but can you actually
go do something with it
to change people's lives?
Change operational
behavior out in the field.
So I know I've got
many different people
in the audience,
some of you won't
understand how did you do it.
So let's start at the
architecture, work our way up.
So here on the left
some obvious candidates.
We've got some batch data,
had to look at long term
risk factors.
Things like drought, obvious
contributor to flammability.
Had to look at the
electrical utility
assets, parts of
the transmission
and the distribution grid.
What's their age?
What's their condition?
What's been the maintenance
on those assets?
I had to look at the historical
weather, where was it windy?
When was it wet and raining?
And then, of course, what
we're trying to predict, fires.
Then we also got to work with
some streaming data using
Pub/Sub in particular, we
had the utility management
activity.
The electrical grid,
while it's been around
for over 100 years
in some locations,
we're constantly
doing work on it.
We're changing the quality,
we're doing maintenance,
we're doing repairs, and
so I want that information
as soon as we can get it.
Also, we've got vegetation
management activity
that happens every single day.
We've got crews out
trimming trees, looking
at the condition in the right
of way, looking at the condition
adjacent to the right of way.
And then, last, I've
got the weather forecast
because I want to
know what's going
to happen tomorrow and the
day after that and the week
after that.
So we can ingest all of that.
Obviously, we'd have
a tremendous amount
of time series
processing we had to do.
Spun up Dataproc,
was great for that.
We were storing results, both
base data and processed data,
in cloud storage.
And then we had a couple
of different approaches
to our modeling that
evolved over time.
We had the CloudML
Engine, where were running
some of our models,
and then also we
just used the Cloud Datalab.
It was great for just
getting quick answers.
And then we would read all
that out into a front end
because, as a data scientist,
I was really happy back here.
But for my business
users, I needed to publish
and it was great that I could
put results into Cloud SQL
because then they could
feed it into all kinds
of downstream applications.
And then I could put a web
UI on the front, right?
I didn't know who all
the users might be,
but I knew that I could make it
available to them on the Google
Cloud Platform.
This, for us, was very much
a journey of discovery.
We did not sit down in a
conference room and say,
based on everything we know,
let's architect this thing once
and I'm sure we're
going to get it right.
And I think you may
have heard some of that
and what Kenton
talked about as well.
So a couple of
things we learned,
I wanted to share
with you, because you
may go on a similar journey.
One on the left,
the architecture.
We sat down with
the initial design.
Our feeling was, this is
probably a good start,
we got started.
And we learned, we didn't
nail it the first time.
But there are some
great tools out there.
In particular, the official
icons and the sample diagrams
was great as we could bring
in subject matter experts
and talk about the problem,
talk about the data,
talk about the challenges we had
and some of the ETL processes
and say, does this
feel like something
that's been solved before?
Does Google already have
tools and accelerators
that we could use?
And the answer was yes.
Also, on the pricing.
I'm in a professional
services organization.
People always ask me, how
long is it going to take?
What's it going to cost?
And so some of the pricing
wasn't known, right?
The answer is, well, depends
how fast you want to go?
How soon do you want it?
So we had some great--
we used the pricing
calculators that worked really
well because I could then put
that back into my client's hand
and say, it's your decision.
The tools are here.
They will support you to do it.
It's really what's
your budget and what's
your demand in the market.
Also, the inexperience
with the new tools.
The Google Cloud Platform
continues to evolve.
You saw today.
We've got new tools
available to us.
There's also been an
evolution of the tools
we were using while
we were using them.
And that worked really
well, but it meant
we weren't always experienced.
So I could take junior
folks and get them involved,
build on what they already
knew, and then get them
deeper into the Google
Cloud ecosystem.
So that was really great for
building morale in the team
and sustaining the
energy on this project.
We also dealt a lot
with the complexity
in building the data
science pipelines.
There is a lot of
math, it's complex.
But what I've found is I could
tell people, just go try it,
just get started.
I could put the
tools in their hands
and it worked really well.
They could do prototyping,
they could get into Sheets,
we could say, here's
what I want to do,
now I want to do it even bigger.
I'm kind of excited about
the AutoML work and some
of the connected Sheet
stuff we saw today.
I might be using
that by next week.
And then, the other
thing is, because I
had a smaller, very high-trust
team, it was great for me.
I had great visibility
and my whole team
had visibility to
each other's work.
And so that made
it very efficient.
If somebody was out or they
had a question how it was done,
I could always get
to the repository,
I could see the work, I
could see the workflow.
And if my leadership wanted
to audit and understand
or my client wanted
to dig deeper,
it's all there for them to see.
It's transparent.
And then, the last
part, the DevOps basics.
This stuff will kill you if
you don't think about it.
It's a lot harder.
If you did it the old way, it
took a lot of time and money.
So I was very excited.
We felt that natively building
these applications in GCP
cut out a lot of time and cost.
For those of you who
like the pretty pictures,
here's an example on your left
of one of our early models.
You can see some of
the utility footprint,
you can see some of the trees,
some of the risk factors
are modeled out in the grid.
And that was great.
We got an answer.
But, of course, that very
day we read out the results
we've got it.
I think we've got it.
I got asked, well,
hey, this is great.
Can we expand the spatial scope?
Can we build out
to adjacent states?
Can we go to other
utilities and territories,
because we trade power with them
and if they go down I go down?
We got asked for
expanded temporal scope.
Can you take more time?
How about could we
add more variables?
Oh, I've got a
really great idea,
I met somebody who's
in forestry and he
was explaining to me the physics
and how the different species
of trees have different
elasticities in the wind,
like, hey, yes.
We're on a platform
where we can do that.
Really what we're left with
are our business priorities.
Which one do you want
to bite off first?
That allowed us to run
lots of model variants
as well to explore to the extent
the research was not clear
and there were
opportunities for us
to work and expand on
some of the research
that the universities had done.
We were able to do that.
And, ultimately, I'm
a business person.
Could we make it actionable?
Could we make it easier for
the downstream applications
to consume this information
and change the work orders that
go out tomorrow to actually make
a difference out in the world?
The other piece of this
is really interesting
if you come at it from
a policy perspective.
So we put together the
model that already--
let's talk about the
accuracy and the precision
and the recall.
Let's get into the numbers.
And that's, of
course, important.
Obviously along the diagonal
here, the true positives,
right?
The ones we got right.
Also important,
the true negatives.
We predicted no fire,
there was no fire.
But let's talk about
the off diagonal.
This is really interesting
policy discussion.
In the bottom left
corner, we predicted
there would be a fire.
But in fact, there wasn't any.
So what's the harm?
What have we done when
we're wrong in this model?
I've sent somebody
out to trim trees.
Well, the utility
is obligated to go
through the whole
territory every year,
every two years,
every four years.
It depends on the
risk and where you
are with the utility, what the
regulation is in your state.
But, really, I've maybe
accelerated when we got to it.
But nobody's been harmed.
It's just relatively
low cost for something
I was going to do
operationally anyway.
The top rate is the one
you don't want to be wrong.
That's when we say, I don't
think that's the dangerous one,
but it turns out it was.
So when we got into all the
hyperparameter tuning, that's
the one where you said, I
got to make that thing as
small as possible.
Every data set you can give
me, every transformation you
can think of, and I was never
limited by the platform.
I'm limited by our imagination,
by the research, and by time.
Some examples, then, we
also found was helpful.
You got great big data sets and
want to know, so where were we
right?
Where were we wrong?
Two examples up here,
false positives.
These are actually
kind of a fun story.
I was wrong because
we got there early.
I told you 12 hours
before it failed,
I thought it was going to fail.
So in my mind, that's
actually a success story.
I was wrong, but the impact of
that is you were to cut it down
and we'd all be a lot happier.
But on the right-hand side,
some that we got right.
Not only the location
and the time,
we understood the conditions.
And that made us feel
like we've got this.
This is good enough that we
can start to operationalize
and we can roll it out, we can
make decisions with this data,
with this model with this team.
So a couple of takeaways.
First, we really had
a great experience
with the Google Cloud Platform.
It's an ecosystem,
it's scaled for us
and allowed us to integrate,
and it allowed our product
development team to get out
and come up with new ideas.
And I never had to tell them
the technology doesn't do that.
You'd say, yeah, we can do that.
And the second part is, there
are a lot of ways to get there.
I showed you one of the
architectures that we
implemented on this journey.
But I would encourage
you to experiment.
It's easy to set up, it's
easy to run through it,
and it's easy to tear down
and try something different.
Think of it as a
journey and think of it
as one that's actually
kind of fun to go on.
The other piece is,
for me, personally,
that efficiency
and the accuracy--
that was so important.
My feeling-- I could get my
team motivated every single day
and say, today we're
going to make it better.
We're going to build
on everything we had.
It was all there.
And we had a way to share those
learnings with each other.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Once again.
Thank you very much for
attending this session
and thank you again to
all of our presenters
from Chevron,
Hitachi, and Nissen.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]